très bien guillaume n'est pas sa liberté
les autres oui c'est vrai alors les
biens de bien sûr bien sûr bailly nos
pays ne peuvent que dire il va pas assez
loin il faut et eux et ont rajouté en
disant par exemple il aurait fallu
abrogé lisf complètement ce que
d'ailleurs je trouve je trouve tout à
fait eu tout à fait sensé ce qu'il ya un
paradoxe dans cette es yessef c'est que
macro ont réussi à mécontenter beaucoup
de monde
les une partie des couches populaires
qui sont heurtés par cette mesure
il donne aussi un argument à gauche
contre lui et en même temps il rend fou
de rage les ceux qui vont rester
assujettis à l isf et qui paradoxalement
sont souvent moins fortunés ils sont les
et bien sûr mais si on ne paierait pas
les sf c'est entendu mais ils sont pas
pour autant riches entre aisée et riche
il ya des nuances et et donc on a le
sentiment qui veut promouvoir un modèle
de réussite sociale qui finalement ne
peut pas fédérer beaucoup parce que ça
s'adresse nécessairement à des gens trop
peu nombreux et ça c'est un problème
parce que ça se détache trop trop
ostensiblement des des traditions
françaises où il ya déjà le rapport
catholique compliquée avec l'argent qui
veut qu'on a cette fois ce fameux tabou
de l'usf
on peut aussi puiser argumente
économiquement sur la nécessité de le
supprimer bon c'est toujours assez
toujours des difficiles on a vu à quel
point gouvernement et paraît tout à fait
démunis face aux attaques de président
des riches
tous les députés en marche à l'assemblée
qu'on nous avait présenté comme des
entrepreneurs dynamiques de la société
civile vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir mais je les ai pas beaucoup vu je
sais pas beaucoup entendus pour défendre
cette répondre aux attaques qui sont
adressés sur sur macro et finalement le
la tradition française qui veut quand
même que un travailleur indépendant qui
a bien réussi dans sa vie cabossée comme
un damné avec ça avec son épouse par
exemple et qui se retrouvent assujettis
à l isf et que normalement quand il est
propriétaire d'un bel appartement il
peut pas espérer arriver plus loin
socialement il se sent dans le champ de
vision de la réussite de mâcon c'est ça
qui est très étonnant du coup il est
vexé l'ordre